[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
J'ai vu le grand-père la dernière fois
2000 et le corps est comme une énorme baleine
il n'a pas d'écailles et ressemble à une peau d'éléphant
au-dessus du gris foncé et comme
il atteignait le ventre plus clairement et
Ils ont des nageoires et une très longue queue.
Fini qui joue Timon
ils ont un cou très haut
et la petite tête et je calcule plus ou
moins d'environ 12 mètres
énorme
[Musique]
quand je l'ai bien vu à long terme
J'ai cherché rapidement dans l'encyclopédie pour voir
Ce n'est pas vrai les dessins que j'ai de
l'encyclopédie alors j'ai dit oh tu es un
plétosaure
[Musique]
tout le monde disait le monstre du lac
Pourquoi un monstre ? Alors je dis que c'est un
grand-père un animal préhistorique et depuis
Ils s'appellent donc Nahuelito Nahuel el
lac
et a ajouté le grand-père
[Musique]
à la contemplation
Cela s'est produit à cinq kilomètres d'ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les mesures estimées
ils mesuraient environ 22 à 25 mètres
long sur le dos, il avait deux hémisphères et
ces hémisphères avaient un très
surtout qu'il était vert
quand il est parti il ​​a fait beaucoup de vagues sur la côte
[Musique]
fabriqué à partir de carburant
nous étions environ un groupe de 20 personnes
des gens qui, lorsqu'ils ont vu l'ampleur
ils ont été très surpris
est resté à nos yeux
environ 20 minutes une demi-heure
C'était une coïncidence si je n'étais pas avec
lui parce que je l'ai beaucoup accompagné
J'ai suivi les voyages qu'il faisait
il avait presque neuf dix ans et quand il
je suis rentré à la maison pour discuter de ce qui se passait
c'est arrivé, je disais comment pourrais-je le manquer
J'ai aussi eu un sentiment de peur
les fois suivantes qui l'accompagne à
il
dans le bateau, c'est bien d'être toujours
attentif aux couleurs des mouvements
qui surgit au fur et à mesure qu'on se sillonne
le lac
[Musique]
On disait que sur l'île qu'on voit ici
derrière le fond il y avait des Pumas
c'est pourquoi ils l'ont nommée l'île de Los Tigres
ou l'île aux lions
quand nous parlons de Nahualito, nous sommes
Je parle toujours de quelque chose d'inconnu
beaucoup croyaient qu'il y avait un plésiosaure
dans cet endroit et c'est
très difficile
les voisins parlent de nahualito avec
ils parlent beaucoup d'amour
je n'ai pas eu l'occasion de voir
grand-père comme certaines personnes
ils prétendent l'avoir vu, j'ai vu des choses
que je ne peux pas savoir s'ils le sont vraiment
événements physiques qui se produisent
une cause de réaction chimique sous
surface sûrement Non n'a pas été ni
un animal, loin de là, c'est un lac
que tu as un mystère et j'ai le
chanceux de vivre au bord du lac
Nahuel Huapi je vois toute la nuit
choses intéressantes
luminescences dans le lac
les choses sont vues
étrange disons
La Patagonie, au fil des années, a
transformé en un lieu
de beaucoup de magie et de mystère
premières histoires connues
Ils parlent d'un lieu plein de mystères
plein de mort même sur les cartes
de l'Antiquité figurait comme le pays
du diable San Carlos de Bariloche était
à ses débuts
une région de peuplement
nomades des communautés nomades du
Tehuelches il y a des milliers d'années et avec le
le temps s'est transformé en un
petite ville qui était une colonie
L'élevage agricole au fil du temps
le tourisme a marqué l'orientation économique de la
ville
et je suis arrivé à ce qui est à ce que je suis
Bref, c'est un endroit comme un village de
montagne dont je suis fier
vivre
étoilé
quand je suis arrivé il y a une cinquantaine d'années
Bariloche n'existait pas ici, c'était un village
tout n'a pas explosé, il n'y avait pas d'égout
il n'y avait pas de lumière, ni penser au téléphone, ni
câbler rien
[Musique]
pour la première fois
Je dois supposer que c'était en 1910 la deuxième
plus tard, c'était en 1936
et la quatrième fois en 1957 puis en 1986
et les dernières apparitions en 2006 dans le
moment où nous parlons d'un
précieuxsaure qui a disparu il y a 65 ans
des millions d'années
C'est un peu difficile, ils vont prendre ça comme
une chose très folle
et je n'étais pas le seul à l'avoir vu parce que deux
plus de gens qui l'ont vu mais ne l'ont pas fait
Je ne voulais rien dire parce qu'ici, quand tu
tu vois quelque chose d'extraordinaire que disent les gens
j'en ai pris trop
nous allons dire que le prix du balaou
Grand-père a donné à cet endroit un
résonance osseuse avec mon grand-père
Bariloche a grandi avant que vous ne viviez différemment
façon dont ils vivaient de la pêche dans le lac de
les cultures en changement maintenant Bariloche
vit d'un tourisme une fois que
grand-père a été installé dans l'esprit
de personnes beaucoup de personnes de
Buenos Aires beaucoup de touristes beaucoup de monde
d'autres parties du monde voulaient venir
voyons ce monstre
[Musique]
les mapuches
cuir
les vieux colons les mapuches qui
Ils ont peuplé toute cette région et sont toujours
en volant, ils avaient une très légende
surtout que c'était la légende du cuir
qu'ils voyaient le cuir comme du cuir
flottant dans le lac qui a pris le
les animaux
c'est grâce à cela qu'il est devenu populaire
la relation entre le monstre a commencé
en 1910, où pour la première fois un
M. nommé George Garrett
qui était en fait le premier
voyant
au monstre lui-même qu'il
Il a dit qu'il avait vu une bosse flotter
le lac de sept mètres de long
cette nouvelle est arrivée
vite et bien ils ont commencé à parler
des animaux que l'on pouvait trouver
des États-Unis, cela a dit Oui
nous avons toujours dit ça
La Patagonie pourrait avoir des anti-animaux
déluges
Et bien sûr, qui devait apparaître
j'ai dit que je l'avais vu Martin Sheffield
chercheur d'or typique d'Amérique du Nord et
conduire un personnage de ceux-là Ce n'est pas
VRAI
[Musique]
de Buenos Aires
qui était à l'époque directeur du
Zoo de Buenos Aires avec les armés
une expédition pour venir ici et
pouvoir capturer le monstre du lac pour
Bien sûr, je n'ai capturé aucun monstre
il n'y a rien que je t'ai mentionné là-dedans
à ce moment-là, il a donné deux mille pesos forts à
Martin à ce moment-là je parle de
1922 environ
pour avoir fait tout ce mouvement pour
lui avoir parlé du monstre et du reste et
il a gardé ces 2000 pesos
[Musique]
Journalistes correspondants du Carnaval
les habitants envoient des nouvelles Buenos Aires
la capture du plésiosaure acculé
attrapé
c'est le Carnaval
C'est un masque de carnaval
C'est la plus grosse blague jamais faite.
cette région pendant plus d'un siècle et a été
pour ces carnavals qui Le char avec
forme de plésiosaure apparue par
première fois au centre ville
en descendant la rue Mitre et depuis
là la légende ou le mythe du grand père
était en vigueur et avait une présence dans le
patrimoine traditionnel ou culturel du
Ville de Bariloche
dans les premiers carnavals de Bariloche
l'un des éléments qui ont dominé le
scène dans la rue la plus éthique de
Bariloche, le seul à cette époque était
Figurine Préciosaure de Clemente
Onelli ou Martin Sheffield sont apparus
cette silhouette énorme défilant à travers le
rues et c'est ainsi que ce mythe a été créé
vérité ou réalité qui est notre célèbre
et cher nahuelito, pourquoi commences-tu à
j'adore un personnage que tu ne connais pas
mais
est devenu une riche histoire pour
cette région et dans un élément de
promotion du tourisme Comme personne ne l'avait fait
soupçonné l'arrivée du chemin de fer
plus les légendes du monstre du lac
Nahuel Huapi et tout le reste réalisé
un contingent de touristes
approche la zone je t'en dis même plus
connaître la région parce que pour y arriver
Bariloche à cette époque n'était pas très facile
à cette époque les crayons pour
l'écriture était faite de bois avec une feuille
plus tard, ils n'en fabriquèrent pas
la petite tête du plésiosaure et tout le
les enfants des écoles voulaient en avoir un
stylo plésiosaure
il y avait des cigarettes de marque plésiosaure
et même un tango que je vous montre ici
le plésiosaure
[Musique]
l'écharpe
et les nouvelles sortent, plus de touristes sont aperçus
le phénomène de Nahuel Huapi nouveau
des témoignages sur une vision étrange de ceci
il y a des notes et des notes le grand-père 2 a
voisin un cher voisin
il l'a appelé grand-père, il n'a pas cherché
quel nom mon grand-père s'est-il donné
première apparition à l'été 1994
alors notez si vous remarquez un autre étranger
observation dans le lac Nahuel Huapi
il y a eu un boom des apparitions entre les années 70
et le 80 pour moi tout ce genre de
les animaux existent
[Musique]
et je ne vais pas à ta preuve scientifique
Parce que si je dois passer des tests
scientifique, je dois dire non
n'existe pas
Michelangelo Rossi réaliste
[Musique]
Je développe un projet qui est
traitement de surface à la flamme
principalement sur la question de
mythe du grand-père au lac Nahuel
huapi de Patagonie ce projet
entend précisément que mettre le
spectateur sous-marin qui toujours
nous voyons chaque jour ce que nous vivons ici
à San Carlos de Bariloche nous sommes
filmer à plusieurs mètres
profondeur et nous trouvons des choses
vraiment intéressant ce lac a un
profondeur qui était il y a de nombreuses années
enregistré 500 mètres mais
les études les plus récentes montrent que
il peut y avoir plus de 800 places presque
1000 mètres
les observations des grands-parents ont
avait
historiquement trois endroits où
vu plus il y a un endroit qui s'appelle la
Zone de 500 mètres
il est né un bras qui s'appelle le bras
tristesse qui est l'un des endroits où
il a vu plus de fois grand-père
[Musique]
Grand-père est tout un phénomène pour
habitants de cette région et bien plus encore
même pour les visiteurs je n'en avais pas
expérience
concernant une vue ou quelque chose qui est
cela ressemble à un mouvement étrange dans le
lac nahuel huapi malgré avoir
né à Bariloche Oui, je l'avais pour moi
profession et parce que j'ai pris beaucoup de notes,
histoire de voisins qui prétendent avoir
vu ce que nous définissons aujourd'hui comme un
Grand-père
avec des proches d'un personnage important
homme d'affaires décédé dans l'année
Il y avait quatre trois hommes d'affaires et un
directeur de banque
familles connues d'ici à Bariloche
C'était un jour comme aujourd'hui le fameux calme
chicha il n'y avait pas de houle au lac nahuel
les huapi étaient dans un bateau très sûr
et tout d'un coup, la nouvelle fut
qu'ils ont disparu, le bateau est resté
la cloche était baissée
quatre personnes sont apparues, trois corps
l'autre est toujours porté disparu et était un
vrai, on ne sait pas pourquoi ils étaient
ils pêchaient parce qu'ils étaient vieux parce que
ils ne roulaient pas à grande vitesse dans le
bateau parce qu'il n'y avait pas de vent à ce moment-là
tout cela, c'est comme se nourrir ou
renvoie la possibilité que
en effet dans le lac Nahuel Huapi
quelque chose existe, il y a quelque chose qui existe encore
nous ne savons pas
Je pense que grand-père est un mythe pour
certains sont une réalité si cela se produit déjà
être à nous
Si ce n'est pas le cas, nous félicitons ceux qui
Ils ont raconté une histoire à une légende
fiction qui a déjà atteint les plans
télévision internationale de temps en temps
quand il montre l'histoire de certains
voisin la radio fait pareil et quoi
ils ont fortement pris ce sont les
dessinateurs ou dessinateurs
peux-tu imaginer ça mon grand-père comme
personnage central et mascotte de ce
ville tous les cinq ans Nous parlons
fortement de sa part
environ dans cinq ans, vous pouvez avoir un
histoires d'apparitions histoires qui disent
après avoir vu mon grand-père, je suis revenu
comme un profond silence où personne
parle jusqu'à ce qu'il se lève à nouveau
une autre histoire populaire, le personnage de ceci
petit animal
[Musique]
Je n'ai pas personnellement vu mon grand-père
si j'ai vu deux ou trois films
m'a vraiment fait réfléchir
assez parlé de son existence.
J'adorerais le voir s'il existe Oui
Oui, je fais attention à ces gens qui
ils disent qu'ils l'ont vu parce que généralement
les yeux ne mentent pas et j'ai ajouté ça au
tradition à un peu d'histoire
de sa présence de son existence il y a
donner du crédit à ceux qui le font
ils disent qu'ils existent grand-père
les observations de grand-père toujours
ont été faits à l'époque où dans le lac
c'est très calme qu'il semble que ce soit
comme on dit ici repassé comme si c'était le cas
une huile à l'époque
se peut voir
des mouvements internes sont visibles
mouvements de l'eau et vous pouvez voir
émerger alors que les reins du rivage ont
vu, j'ai vu, beaucoup ont pris
les photos ont été filmées
mais ils ne se démarquent pas trop pour ça
le lac doit être très calme
Je pense
que comme il n'y avait pas de vagues à cause de la houle
renouvelle l'oxygène dans l'eau
au lieu de cela, le lac était toujours calme
toujours en train de repasser
Et sûrement ils ont fait surface
s'oxygéner pour
sentir l'oxygène ne semble pas froid ou
quelque chose comme ça, c'était vraiment très long.
étouffant et ils sont sortis
protégés par l'île, ils ne sont pas sortis
ouvertement
[Musique]
de toutes les observations, certaines
un terrain d'entente sur tout
quand les gens disent ça
apparaît comme s'il s'agissait de l'arrière d'un
baleine avec un bruit très fort
à plusieurs endroits, c'est courant
même avec une histoire différente de
beaucoup d'années
et il y a quelques histoires
très fort aussi là où
assurer que ce longe qui a émergé du
Lago a eu une influence sur certains
accidents survenus dans le lac
avec des bateaux et avec des pêcheurs avec
les familles qui naviguaient pas le
la plupart des vidéos semblent montrer
quelque chose mais ce n'est rien j'en ai vu beaucoup
des choses qui sont des malles que j'ai même vues
images de certains animaux
ils appellent ça, ils sont comme de grosses loutres
J'ai vu des vagues ce qu'on appelle parfois les
fameuse vague unique quand le lac est très
repassage, il y a des courants internes qui
Ils soulèvent une vague et puis c'est fini
il y a des vidéos qui ont vraiment
surpris et je ne peux pas dire ce que c'est mais
Ce n'est ni une bûche flottante ni des tyrans
nager ni la seule vague
La Patagonie a toujours été très dure depuis
du début à la fin et bien plus encore
dur c'est au bout du monde où
ils appellent la fin du monde pas à Ushuaia
terre de feu les légendes
Patagonie, par exemple, que vous avez le
cité des Césars tu as la légende
Eh bien, tu as une infinité de cuir
les choses qui font de la Patagonie un lieu
Si tu veux dire un peu enchanté là
différentes cultures dont si l'une
apprendre
Vous avez avant tout une richesse totale
la culture des gens du pays, pas ça
les premiers étaient les initiateurs
qui a peuplé pour la première fois la Patagonie
En fait, il existe des enregistrements datant d'il y a 17 000 ans.
des années, ces monstres que tu vois ici
proviennent souvent de la tradition
la tradition est transmise oralement
disons non
La Patagonie est magnifique, il y en avait déjà
dit Darwin lors de son voyage ici à
1833 est un musée géant est un lieu
où les fossiles abondent
Un plésiosaure est un animal qui possède
le long cou a quatre nageoires, deux
avant et deux arrière et une queue
c'étaient des animaux purement aquatiques voir un
plésiosaure aujourd'hui dans un lac, c'est comme
voir un homme vieux d'un million d'années
marcher dans la rue est techniquement
impossible il y a 65 millions d'années
Les prix des Sauriens disparaissent et c'est
impossible pour eux d'exister aujourd'hui
cela ne veut pas dire que la nature
nous en avons réservé
surprendre
ils ont peut-être encore survécu
certains animaux comme le cœlacanthe
exemple que c'est un poisson qui a été trouvé dans
L'Inde existe depuis environ 60 ans.
on le croyait éteint il y a 65 millions d'années
années
et ce poisson formait des hybrides hybrides
hybrides jusqu'à la flèche d'aujourd'hui
Je suppose que si c'est ce poisson
Il aurait dû disparaître il y a 65 ans
des millions d'années et ce n'est pas le cas parce que ce n'est pas le cas
aurait pu survivre et faire
j'ai vécu une chose précieuse, il y a un travail
réalisé par des scientifiques de
Université du Sud de l'Argentine
où ils découvrirent que le fameux
longes que l'on voit naviguer sur l'eau
Ce sont des bulles de gaz sortant d'un
faute qu'il y a dans le lac Nahuel Huapi
qu'ils forment
comme si c'était le dos d'un plésiosaure
c'est naviguer dans ces bulles de gaz
sont produits parce que nous sommes
dans un bassin pétrolier, nous
Nous avons une culture très, très technologique.
la technologie partout qui n'existe pas
c'est faux, bien sûr, c'est bien, mais
beaucoup d'entre nous n'oublient pas
de ce qu'est la terre de ce qu'est la
la terre nous donne ce qu'elle nous donne
enseigner donc nous ne pouvons pas
Accepter
Comment puis-je vous dire que je crois que
il peut y avoir un monstre dans un lac
comment une telle chose peut exister
[Applaudissements]
certains disent que le lac nahuel huapi
a des liens avec l'océan Pacifique
c'est pour ça qu'ils disent que grand-père viendrait
de l'océan Pacifique jusqu'ici mais ça
c'est impossible aussi disent les chiliens
que cet animal est vu dans le Pacifique
Maintenant, comment arrive-t-il ici? Je pense que le
La Cordillère n'est pas une masse mais il y a
sous terre parce que sinon comment cela pourrait-il être
Que le lac est toujours le même
hauteur car avec la pluie ça ne pousse pas
et l'océan Pacifique était là et le
nahuel huapi ici sur le web guapi
j'aurais de l'eau salée oui et si j'allais au
inverser que je le tourne à pied C'est plus haut
que le Pacifique
les eaux du nahuel huapi couleraient
dans le Pacifique et non dans l'Atlantique et si
étaient tous les deux au même niveau, il y aurait
Il me faudrait une très grande grotte
[Musique]
le sentiment que j'ai de vivre ici est
de liberté d'air pur sur l'ensemble
silence
et tôt le matin j'entends le
des oiseaux
et j'ai une coquille qui est un est un
le bateau va bien gros gris qui s'arrête
en haut du poteau et nous avons un
conversation
j'ai une connexion
très fort avec la nature
en général
autant qu'il s'agit d'arbres, de plantes et
les animaux
dans les cultures autochtones sont très
différents de nos cultures, ils
ils respectent la terre ils respectent leur
les traditions respectent leurs citations
ses monstres ses êtres mythologiques
ils les respectent parce que cela fait partie de leur
la vie sur terre en fait partie
ils l'appellent monstre
De quel droit avons-nous ?
trouvons des animaux qui ne sont pas les mêmes
c'est ce que nous savons et je ne sais pas
ressemble à un cheval ou à une abeille ou à un
chien
pourquoi devons-nous aller appeler le
monstres
quand il est apparu
là-bas, sur l'île, ils étaient bien plus gros que moi
ça devait être la femelle et deux autres
petits
ils jouaient là, c'est pour ça qu'ils
éclaboussant comme qui dit non, c'est vrai
maman avec les garçons sur la plage
et ça et c'est pour ça que je pouvais les voir tous
corps qui ne sont pas terrestres qui
ils ont des nageoires quatre nageoires, j'ai adoré
les voir. Ce n'est pas vrai qu'ils étaient
gratuit et en cela
celle que je supposais était la femelle
s'arrêta brusquement et regarda du côté du
Le lac et les bateaux du Yacht Club sont venus
Alors j'ai commencé à crier ici
[Musique]
une folle
s'ils m'ont écouté ou s'ils ne m'ont pas écouté
question qu'ils m'ont fait disparaître
sous l'eau
nous sommes une proie nous n'allons pas le faire
étude
une créature comme tu dis qu'elle est
en nageant dedans, nous allons enquêter
vois ce que c'est parce que c'est ici
on y va directement avec un arbono avec un
bombe que nous devons détruire
au lieu de cela, les gens avant notre
les ancêtres n'ont pas fait ça Aux tests
qu'il y a des circonstances d'un
observation ou une photographie qui
soi-disant, ça peut être pris
occasionnellement mais preuve scientifique
scientifique non pas parce que pour le
scientifiques
très difficile de croire qu'un animal de ce genre
caractéristiques d'une bête de ceux-là
les fonctionnalités peuvent avoir survécu
Trop de ces changements climatiques et
le reste
chaque légende vient d'une réalité
d'abord il y a la réalité ensuite
devient une légende et puis
déjà devenu un mythe
une des versions qui affirment que le
grand-père n'existe pas
Je le tire des expériences d'un
vieux capitaine décédé aujourd'hui
s'appelait Don Fernando Galiani du
Années 1930 quand il a commencé à naviguer
au lac Nahuel Huapi
J'ai soutenu que la présence de mon grand-père
n'était ni plus ni moins que ce qu'il
appelé la vague morte
cette théorie que j'avais comme
valide m'a fait
réfléchissez à la possibilité que
vraiment l'animal
existait parce qu'un jour un ami descendait
le mien en descendant le clocher a vu un
mouvement bizarre dans le lac plus ou moins
entre le mouvement et la chaise environ deux
kilomètres
et il a pointé son appareil photo et l'a apporté avec
le zoom et c'était un corps qui était
en mouvement
qui remontait à la surface
former un cercle une courbe dans
en fait très proche de la côte du bras
clocher presque en surface car le
la couleur du corps était plus ou moins
grisâtre gris clair dans ma mémoire et
revenait toujours dans une courbe pour s'enfoncer dans le
de l'eau et ceux-ci ont vraiment disparu
images
ils nous ont fait penser que peut-être
tout animal vivant se trouvait dans le
les profondeurs de Nahuel Huapi parce que
Je le répète, un coffre ne monte pas de courbe
à la surface et redescendre
une trajectoire planifiée mais qui
j'ai vraiment eu la vie et je devrais l'être
assez gros ceux d'entre nous qui étaient plus
sceptique quant à l'idée de commencer sa vie dans le
présence de mon grand-père la vérité que
à ce moment-là, nous lui avons fait douter du pourquoi
au moins il y avait quelque chose sous le lac
mais je ne savais pas très bien
[Musique]
de la télévision nationale
je pense qu'il y a quelque chose de similaire
demande à une raie pastenague, je pense qu'il y en a
un couple ou
un individu qui est
ceci et cela, il peut vivre tranquillement ou
être soutenu du lac calmement
J'ai été surpris de voir quelque chose
flottant dans le lac, c'était comme un
ballon noir arrivant à toute vitesse
de la péninsule de San Pedro
du bas de la Cordillère
Je suis allé chercher la vision à long terme pour
concentre-toi mieux
et quand
Je me concentre à long terme, je vois que cette chose
le noir qui flottait n'était pas un ballon commun
ni un sous-marin comme je le pensais
parce qu'il avait un très long cou
avec la tête haute pour dire que je pensais que
c'était le périscope et quand j'ai vu tous les
corps
J'ai rapidement cherché une feuille pour le dessiner et
J'ai appelé la radio pour dire oui pour
S'il vous plaît, regardez parce que je ne voulais pas être le
c'est unique que j'aie vu un tel animal
J'ai un appareil photo, des photos mais je n'en avais pas
rouler
pas vrai et
le stétosaure ne m'a pas prévenu parce que
téléphone quand il est venu
peut-être qu'il est venu beaucoup plus de fois que moi
Je ne pouvais pas le voir, pas à partir de la date à laquelle il est arrivé
les deux fois, les trois fois où je l'ai vu
le lac a été repassé il n'y avait pas
le temps était très oppressant
pour moi il se nourrit d'algues tu ne lui donnes pas
ni la bouche pour manger une personne
Si jamais c'est arrivé
manger un être humain serait mort
empoisonné
parce que nous sommes si mauvais
nous respirons tellement de mal que cela aurait
poison mort mon pauvre grand-père
[Musique]
Prenons en compte un détail
intéressant les lacs, ce ne sont pas des lacs
très vieux leur antiquité est ronde entre
un million et demi d'années
à peu près ainsi
entre l'espace de 65 millions d'années
il y a un million et demi où il vivait
grand-père si le lac n'existait pas
grand-père ne pouvait pas exister
ces animaux étaient de l'eau
techniquement chaleureux car ceux du
Le système Jurassique et Crétacé avait des mers
avec des eaux légèrement plus chaudes mais
C'est peut-être parce qu'on l'observe davantage dans
l'été qu'en hiver en hiver ici
Il fait très froid et ça ne donne pas grand chose
reste au bord du lac pour regarder et voir
ce qui se passe et il y a beaucoup de choses
le vent, l'eau bouge plus
contrairement à l'été que l'eau
c'est encore plus et peut-être que ce sera le cas
Ils voient certaines choses mais ce n'est pas le cas
indicatif pour dire qu'en été
viens plus qu'en hiver je pourrais te le dire
en été, les bulles de gaz sont
plus soluble et lève avec beaucoup plus
plus facile qu'en hiver apparemment
il y aurait des animaux rares dans différents
endroits dans le monde où personne n'est vraiment
scie
nous n'avons pas non plus vu Dieu et cru en Dieu
ce n'est pas vrai
[Musique]
J'ai une théorie pour moi, il y a des tortues
des géants dans ce lac les scientifiques
Ils disent que non, j'ai eu des tortues
avec mon fils dans les mains des tortues
grands
des tortues dans ce lac
Disons que je pense qu'il y a peut-être eu un
déformation d'une sorte de tortue
C'est une zone de tortues d'autrefois
un long moment
J'espère que des recherches à travers ceci
l'œuvre audiovisuelle me donne raison mais
nous voulons ce qui est mais quelque chose est
certains disent qu'il y a une tortue
géant mais la tortue est un animal
un reptile et dans les eaux froides je ne pense pas
que je pourrais marcher longtemps parce que dans
le milieu de l'hiver gèlerait dans le
les reptiles ont besoin de chaleur pour vivre
eau froide
à cette époque, à cette époque où nous sommes
je vis tout ce que je te cache dans le
enquête sur les ovnis, tout est scellé
Intégration cryptologique secrète
même
Donc les gens n'ont pas de moyens comme
pour pouvoir chercher, nous en savons plus
espace que ce que nous avons ici
[Musique]
il y a des zones au Congo au Congo Belge
en Afrique encore inexplorables
dans la jungle brésilienne ils suivent
découvrir les tribus indigènes que nous sommes
vivre dans un monde où nous sommes
mettre d'autres sortes de choses dans la tête
[Musique]
si quelqu'un prenait le risque d'enquêter
eh bien, qu'est-ce qui existe dans ce lac?
je pense que ce serait une surprise
Je ne dis pas que tu trouveras un prix
pas de balaou mais tu peux en trouver
bavard qui peut démystifier en
à un moment donné le mythe du grand-père
Non, je n'ai pas vu mon grand-père
la croyance est de lire mon amour
est dans l'enquête en contact
avec les gens d'avoir vu d'avoir
quitté et lu à partir de Rechercher des informations
J'ai toujours été intéressé par tout ce type
des mystères et des énigmes n'est pas d'aujourd'hui
J'ai été dans le
faire des recherches sur toutes ces sortes de choses
des ovnis parapsychologie de l'occultisme
cryptologie tout ce qui a un mot
Mystère que j'aime alors je vais
J'enquête, j'essaye de trouver le oui et le non
le pourquoi et le pourquoi ne pas dire non non
Je suis fan disons que je suis un
personne qui a un critère
Je ne dis pas à tout que tout est un
possibilité spectaculaire qu'il puisse
sois maintenant que je t'assure de
c'est peut-être le cas, je ne sais pas, mais le
la possibilité est
non, je ne perds pas vraiment mon temps avec
des théories qui n'ont rien à voir avec
l'investigation
Je les ai comme référence pour
dis: Eh bien, si quelqu'un me demande quoi
qu'en est-il des sceptiques, et bien des sceptiques
est-ce ceci ceci et cela et qu'en est-il
le vrai, et bien, le réel est ce qu'il voit
témoin, ce qui est réel, c'est ce qu'ils vous disent
Ils sont réels, la photo est bien.
ils peuvent toucher la photo parce que c'est
très très courant aujourd'hui mais il existe des photographies et
photographies Il existe maintenant des techniques qui
on dit bien cette photo est choquante et
celle-ci ne l'est pas et la plupart des photographies qui
ils ont pris ne sont pas trompés parce qu'ils ont
fait toute l'analyse alors ils ont
vrais résultats et avec les théories
tu es prêt
de ce que sont les bulles de ce qu'elles sont
Je les prends comme référence mais je ne le fais pas
Je prends comme une chose comme une chose
réel
nous avons un petit bug qui ressemble à ça
petit, c'est quoi le cafard il y a 400 ans
des millions d'années qui sont sur le
La Terre et ces animaux étaient en train de muter en
oui, ils étaient en train de muter jusqu'à leur arrivée
à ce jour, pourquoi n'aurait-il pas pu y avoir
muté un prix saurien pour atteindre
cette hauteur à cette vie à cette époque
aurait tout aussi bien pu
Je ne peux pas garantir que ce soit le cas
mais si on se base sur ces tests
ils sont énergiques, vous ne pouvez pas dire
non parce que oui
[Musique]
touristes qui arrivent à San Carlos de
Bariloche vient essentiellement chercher
profiter de la nature cette région
a
de nombreuses possibilités pour profiter de
la nature non plus
en été avec les montagnes
avec ses lacs
Un poète l'appela un jour au
région des quatre cieux parce qu'ils sont
bien différencié les quatre saisons
de l'année maintenant au printemps le
la possibilité est de profiter du premier
journées ensoleillées avec 20 22 24 degrés de
température
permettre des activités de plein air
être libre à la fois dans les montagnes et dans
les lacs ou dans les rivières ou dans la steppe
Quelle est cette zone où il n’y a pas de forêt ?
Je dis toujours que ce film va
changer
un peu d'histoire de la ville
la partie scientifique peut justifier tout
leurs paroles et la part des voisins et
les personnes qui ont eu une observation
peut également justifier et nous
nous pouvons connaître en profondeur et revivre
des récréations qui
d'observations et de trouver
peut être
une réponse qui n'a pas encore été donnée
Pas de travail
début du 21ème siècle la présence de
mon grand-père dans toutes les excursions
c'était pratiquement tous les jours tu le voyais
surtout les jours de printemps et
l'été les jours où le lac est calme
Il est repassé. C'est ce que disent les gens.
c'est là que tu peux mieux le voir
entrepreneurs du tourisme en général
les institutions différents dirigeants
On ne parle pas de nahuelitos si le
société le voisin commun alors que
c'est très intéressant à sauver
manifestation
[Musique]
la dernière référence que j'avais dans le
2006 mais soi-disant de 2006 à
2013 Quelques années se sont écoulées et des observations
Il en aura vu beaucoup, je ne dirai pas non avant
maintenant 6 500 espèces sont apparues
totalement différent des animaux
inconnu Même aujourd'hui, il y a des animaux
tu ne sais pas comment les classer
Avez-vous vu que chaque animal a son nom ?
les scientifiques, pas les scientifiques, le savent
mettre à déterminer quel genre de
animaux Eh bien, aujourd'hui, il y en a beaucoup
énorme de ces nouvelles espèces qui
toujours dans les grands centres je ne sais pas
peut classer
nous habitons
une planète presque inconnue le message
que pour moi tout cela a cette histoire
le millénaire c'est prenons soin de la nature
dis, fais attention au lac qui se trouve
très mignon mais tu peux te noyer
essayer de
caresser et respecter beaucoup le lac
Los Arroyos, un peu plus au sud, sont les
glace continentale C'est la
interprétation que je fais ça
animaux avec des pièces de monnaie femmes
Ce sont des animaux qui viennent déjà d'un
tradition
Parce que si nous parlons ou parlons de
sasquatch par exemple grosse peau los
Indiens d'Amérique du Nord, les Chech
navajos, tous ces anasasi déjà
Ils parlaient de toutes ces sortes d'êtres qui
vécu à cet endroit alors ça vient de
une tradition et tu ne peux pas être pour
moi, ça ne peut pas être le cas de toutes les cultures
de ces personnes
tu as vu toutes ces choses et non
existent, les êtres humains doivent croire en
quelque chose en quoi l'être humain doit croire
quelque chose croit en Dieu croit au dans le
ces extraterrestres là-bas, nous pourrions
nous aurions une autre conversation, c'est plus
faisable et nous devons croire en quelque chose et
eh bien, nous croyons en un grand-père et pourquoi
Non
[Musique]